la préhistoire en bande dessinée 45
panneaux ont été installés au coeur du
domaine de saint germain en laye
objectif de l'exposition montré un
panorama de l'art préhistorique
depuis les origines aux alentours de -40
milan jusqu'à la fin du paléolithique
aux alentours de dix mille ans de moins
dix mille ans au moment où le climat se
réchauffe les panneaux mettent en avant
les planches du dessinateur eric lebrun
l'exposition est basé sur les trois
volumes 2 bd l'art préhistorique en
bande dessinée
vous avez ces planches de dessins issus
des trois des trois bd qu'il a réalisé
lors de la prise de la préhistoire et au
verso se trouve en fait une autre bd
dont il est scénariste
les planches sont en lien avec des
objets appartenant aux collections
préhistoriques du musée d'archéologie
nationale des collections pour l'heure
visible en ligne grâce à des qr codes
comme par exemple les venus nous voyons
deux statuettes féminine donc ils
représentent des femmes enceintes qui
ont été trouvés en dordogne une à tursac
et une à sireuil que l'on peut bien sûr
retrouver dans les vitrines du musée
dans la galerie du paléolithique
et puis il ya aussi une petite dame qui
est très connu qu'on appelle la dame à
la capuche
l'exposition s'adresse à tout public une
phase est prévue pour les enfants des
planches sans paroles c'est l'histoire
d'un petit enfant de cro magnon qui
découvre là qu'ils découvrent l'art en
fête en mettant ses mains dans la boue
en laissant des traces derrière lui
voilà et de l'autre côté donc c'est un
petit peu plus pour les parents entre
guillemets donc ça raconte vraiment les
différentes périodes de la préhistoire
une exposition proposée jusqu'à mi
septembre
elle est accessible à tous gratuitement